[Música]
el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo lasso
enfrentará un juicio político después de
más de dos meses de discusiones en la
asamblea nacional y en la corte de
constitucional el 9 de mayo La mayoría
de los legisladores aprobaron que se
haga un proceso para intentar destituir
al mandatario lo acusan de peculado por
permitir que continuara vigente un
contrato por el que la estatal de
transporte de petróleo flopec perdía
millones de dólares en una alianza con
la empresa offshore amazonas tanker pool
el mandatario también ha sido salpicado
por posibles vínculos entre su gobierno
y la mafia albanesa un entramado que
involucra a su cuñado Danilo Carrera la
oposición cercana al ex presidente
Rafael Correa lo sacará del poder o
sobrevivirá lazo al impeachment o
incluso antes declarará la muerte
Cruzada para acabar también con el
legislativo para analizar el tema de hoy
en el debate nos conectamos con quito
donde está André Benavides
constitucionalista y desde portoviejo
nos acompaña también en Ecuador Fernando
casado docente e investigador en la
Universidad Técnica de manabí a ellos
les doy la bienvenida y a ustedes
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar sus comentarios y preguntas
en Twitter Facebook e Instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
piso e.s pueden comentar todo con la
etiqueta numeral el debate f-24 y a mí
me encuentran en las redes como arroba
María claguirre no olviden que todos los
contenidos de nuestros programas están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
quiero entonces darle de nuevo la
bienvenida a nuestros invitados y quiero
comenzar por André Benavides Gracias por
acompañarnos y empecemos por explicarle
a nuestra audiencia En qué consiste la
acusación de peculado que le están
haciendo al presidente y qué es esto de
Amazon Tracker
Muchas gracias por la invitación cordial
saludo para usted y para todos quienes
nos miran a través del debate Pues bien
en la constitución del Ecuador se
establece como una de las causales de
juicio político en su Artículo 129 el
delito de peculado y en el caso
específico se le está siguiendo un
juicio político al presidente de la
república porque presuntamente existir y
existiría un desvío una malversación de
fondos públicos en un contrato que firmó
la empresa pública flopec con amazonas
tanker que es una empresa que se dedica
al tráfico al transporte de crudo Pesado
en ese sentido se ha dicho que el
presidente de la república presuntamente
con su omisión por no haber denunciado a
quienes en ese caso estaban gerenciando
la empresa flopec permitió que se
generen un perjuicio para el Estado
aproximadamente de seis millones de
dólares y esa ha sido la causal de
juicio político sin embargo es
importante tomar en cuenta que ese
contrato entre amazonas tankers y flopec
fue en el gobierno de Lenin Moreno y en
el año 2021 se hace una adenda de ese
contrato y en el año 2022 se renueve el
contrato de manera automática Y esa ha
sido la causal de juicio político por el
cual se le está siguiendo a este proceso
al presidente de la república Guillermo
lasso Fernando quiero continuar con
usted porque Andrés señalaba un punto
que es importante Resaltar aquí y es que
las los tratados que tenía flopec sobre
todo con petrochina para transportar
petróleo ecuatoriano aún así A pesar de
que esto representaba pérdidas para la
transportadora estatal
se hizo en el gobierno de Rafael Correa
fue Entonces que se crearon estos
convenios y como bien lo decía André fue
en 2021 con Lenin Moreno que se hizo la
adenda número tres es decir en pocas
palabras el juicio político que enfrenta
hoy el presidente de derecha Guillermo
lasso es por unos convenios y unos
contratos que comenzaron en la era del
correísmo que responder ante eso bueno
es una forma un poco de ponerlo María
Clara pero en principio El problema es
que si el peculado o el perjuicio para
el Estado comienza en el gobierno lenín
Moreno en principio lo que ocurre es que
afecta son conocidos y no se les pone
ningún tipo de enmienda o solución
durante el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
Pero ese no es realmente el problema no
o sea cuál es el problema de fondo Aquí
María clara que yo creo que es lo que
debemos de analizar ante las crisis
institucionales la Constitución
ecuatoriana ofrece distintas salidas
constitucionales una de ellas es el
juicio político que se establece en el
artículo 129 de la Constitución y en su
apartado 2 habla del peculado Esto es lo
que ha cometido Guillermo lasso peculado
pero en realidad ese no es el problema
María Clara El problema es que venimos
de una situación en la que el presidente
y su gobierno han llevado a cabo una
sistemática vulneración de su propio
programa de gobierno que aparece en un
documento llamado creación de
oportunidades que el presidente
Guillermo lasso viene de perder una
consulta trucha una consulta sesgada que
él presenta y que el 5 de febrero es de
manera masiva rechazada por la
ciudadanía y que venimos de una
situación de crisis en la cual por
ejemplo las inseguridad sea quien
duplicado desde el último año de
gobierno del presidente Rafael Correa
hasta el día de hoy Y entonces la crisis
terrible en la que estamos necesita una
salida ya debería en realidad de haber
renunciado a su cargo el presidente
Guillermo después del 5 de febrero
cuando presentó una consulta popular en
la cual en realidad lo que estaba es
haciendo una especie tercera vuelta una
especie de Buscar oxígeno a sugestión y
fue rechazado ahí ya tendría que haberse
dado cuenta que ya armó lasso que él no
está apto para gobernar porque las
cifras son deleznables pero aún así
continuó empecinado en su gobierno del
desastre y como consecuencia Entonces se
las fuerzas que actualmente componen de
forma muy heterogénea no solamente el
correísmo sino fuerzas de muy diversa
índole desde el centro hasta la
izquierda no solamente el correísmo sino
también pachakuti como un alto
componente indígena también izquierda
democrática como un alto componente de
izquierda centro izquierda liberal
también el partido incluso social
cristiano de corte liberal están
apoyando este
juicio político es decir hay una serie
de fuerzas que se han unido para tratar
de salir de la situación de
institucionalidad en crisis en la que
está en Ecuador Y eso es realmente lo
que importa es flopec que además
recordemos la corte constitucional ya le
ha dado el visto bueno a que se pueda
llevar a cabo el juicio político en
contra del presidente por el peculado en
el cual se incurrió en las
contrataciones de fluopec pero que en
realidad lo trasfondo el trasfondo María
Clara es muy profundo el trasfondo es la
crisis institucional absoluta en la que
está el Ecuador claro usted apunta a
esta crisis institucional para decir no
es solo por el caso del peculado de
flopex sino la reforma constitucional
que pierde el presidente Guillermo lasso
y que tanto impulsó el aumento de la
inseguridad el aumento de los casos de
narcotráfico también están los audios
que han revelado distintos medios de
comunicación Ecuatorianos en los que se
muestra que un amigo de su cuñado su
cuñado es Danilo Carrera y que su amigo
Rubén cherres tendría conexiones con
líderes de la mafia albanesa y que tanto
Rubén como Danilo estarían interfiriendo
en el gobierno de lasso para poner
distintos personajes en ministerios y
todo clave para supuestamente y
presuntamente mover el narcotráfico
Andrés usted está de acuerdo que esto
digamos es un juicio político con el la
excusa del peculado pero que detrás hay
toda una situación que está criticando y
que está presionando a lazo
yo creo que lo que primero tenemos que
tomar en cuenta es que debemos respetar
lo que dice la Constitución de la
República el juicio político es por la
causal de peculado si bien es cierto en
Ecuador Existen varios problemas en
materia de inseguridad en materia de
empleo en materia de Educación en
materia de salud Eso no es la causal de
juicio político decir que eso es la
causal de juicio político es engañar a
la ciudadanía Y si quisiéramos decir que
la causal de juicio político son estos
problemas también tendríamos que ver
aquellos que están en la asamblea
nacional tratando de forzar unas
elecciones anticipadas para ver la forma
de cómo van a llegar al poder en ese
contexto yo creo que debemos ser
respetuosos de la Constitución la corte
constitucional ha dicho la causal de
juicio político especulado y recordemos
dos aspectos fundamentales los
acusadores constitucionales plantea
también como causar la conclusión en
petroecuador y enemco en empresas
públicas y la corte constitucional les
dijo que eso no era admisible y por otro
lado en lo que tiene que ver con la
supuesta relación del gobierno con La
Mafia albanesa la corte constitucional
en el mismo dictamen dijo que el informe
relativo a esos temas tampoco consta
como parte de la acusación
constitucional aquí lo que se debe
demostrar es el peculado y la
responsabilidad política que podría
tener el presidente de la república
algunos dicen no es que esto es político
que sea esto político no significa que
es un juego del todo vale o un cheque en
blanco sino que se requiere demostrar al
menos mínimos que permitan identificar
la existencia de ese peculado En qué
consiste el peculado la malversación de
fondos públicos y si el Constituyente de
montecristi me estableció como causal un
delito yo tengo
tengo que relacionar los hechos con los
elementos del tipo penal y hay algunas
cuestiones que la asamblea nacional no
ha considerado en este caso como por
ejemplo
la distracción de fondos públicos tiene
que ser a favor del lazo o para un
tercero Quién es ese tercero y dónde
está la plata segundo Cuál es el monto
de distracción de fondos públicos no se
ha dicho absolutamente nada y tercero si
es que el presidente de la república
cometió peculado Cuál era la posición
para que él pueda tener la disposición
la libre disposición de esos recursos
para favorecerse o favorecer un tercero
aquí lo que se está haciendo es
generando un escenario para asumir una
responsabilidad de unos pillos de unos
funcionarios pidillos con el único
objetivo de censurar y destituir al
presidente de la república vamos
teniendo Entonces dos visiones que son
diferentes por un lado quienes
consideran como André que esto es un la
oposición de forzar unas elecciones
anticipadas para quedarse con el poder
que perdieron luego de que Guillermo
lasso asumió la presidencia del país en
2021 después de una época de dos
presidencias de Correa y luego su ex
vicepresidente Lenin Moreno que luego
entre grandes comillas traicionó a
Correa y luego llega el banquero lazo a
tomar el poder y por el otro lado
tenemos la visión de Fernando que nos
dice no esto es una institucionalidad
que está en crisis y que necesitamos
cambiar y que lazo necesita renunciar
porque el país lo amerita Fernando en
Esa visión de si para usted entonces no
es una manera de presionar la salida del
gobierno con la que la oposición no está
de acuerdo que responder entonces ante
estas falencias o estos vacíos que está
señalando André y que también están por
ejemplo en el informe de la comisión de
fiscalización que no incluyó dentro del
informe a miembros del correísmo que
estarían involucrados También en estos
posibles casos de corrupción
vale un par de apuntes antes de
contestar la pregunta no antes me
arreglará esa mencionada Rubén cherres
no se te olvidó decir que Rubén Chávez
fue asesinado no apareció encima muerto
no O sea que el escándalo además es
mayúsculo en ese sentido Y en segundo
lugar que en realidad María clara que ya
se ha producido un poco lo que era lo
que ha dicho Andrés benavides no se está
intentando forzar una selección
anticipadas eso lo haría en todo caso
Guillermo lasso en caso de que ya no la
muerte Cruzada que ha amenazado con que
si avanza el juicio político él llamaría
una muerte Cruzada lo cual desnaturaliza
el propio mecanismo del juicio político
que se está llevando a cabo hoy en día
es decir en el momento en el que el
presidente Guillermo lasso vea que puede
tener éxito el mecanismo del juicio
político que lo que hace el juicio
político es destituir al presidente Pero
quien toma la posta es su vicepresidente
con lo cual no hay elecciones
anticipadas cuidado no Benavides
en el sistema saben cómo funciona el
tema del juicio político en cambio
desnaturalizando el juicio político si
llama a las gravas el presidente
Guillermo lasso a una muerte Cruzada ahí
sí disuelve la asamblea gobierna durante
seis meses por decreto y se llama
elecciones ahí sí habría una
anticipación de las elecciones
presidenciales no Y de alguna manera
También tenemos que ver que si se han
puesto tantas fuerzas tan heterogéneas
de acuerdo incluso además sabemos que
existe por el resto de las fuerzas
políticas o un elevado nivel de
anticorreísmo si se están poniendo de
acuerdo con el correísmo que es la
fuerza mayoritaria en cuanto al número
de diputados dentro de la asamblea
nacional algo está ocurriendo en el
Ecuador y por último Por supuesto que el
motivo por el cual se va a llevar a cabo
el juicio político es única y
exclusivamente por el peculado en el que
incurrió el presidente por el caso
flopec y si la comisión de fiscalización
dirigida por un acérrimo anticorreísta y
golazo Fernando villavicencio no ha
incluido una serie de argumentos es
porque el mecanismo que se establece
también legalmente de cómo se presentan
los informes por parte de los
presidentes de las comisiones es que a
última hora independientemente de lo que
se haya acordado en esa comisión que
tenía mayoritaria una mayoría ante la
anticorreísta y prolaso puede el
presidente de la comisión incluir y
sacar los argumentos que le dé la gana
es decir que al final lo que se ha
presentado es un informe totalmente
desvirtuado de lo que realmente se ha
ido discutiendo en la comisión de
fiscalización durante todo este tiempo
por eso pasa ahora al pleno y por eso se
va a discutir ahora en el pleno donde no
pueden utilizarse esos subterfugios y
argucias y ahí es donde vamos a ver
realmente los argumentos y ahí es donde
finalmente se va a votar Y si de 137
escaños se consiguen 92 votos va y
bailaso el problema es que las
obviamente va a accionar antes
desvirtuando el mecanismo del juicio
político la muerte Cruzada y es posible
que esos votos se consigan porque hasta
el momento la asamblea ha tenido más de
104 votos para promover este juicio
político contra lazo ya lo ha tenido en
otras ocasiones Entonces estos votos los
podría obtener Fernando sin embargo una
pregunta si usted no está de acuerdo con
la posición de André que dice que la
oposición quiere forzar unas elecciones
anticipadas si esto no es así como usted
lo plantea Entonces por qué el partido
del expresidente Rafael Correa
renovación ciudadana está promoviendo
abiertamente que lazo llame a una muerte
Cruzada lo que como usted dice traería
elecciones anticipadas
no el movimiento se llama Revolución
ciudadana María Clara
y lo que ocurre es que en este momento
estamos hablando lo que lo que se estaba
discutiendo María Clara es si el juicio
político adelanta o no las elecciones el
juicio político no adelanta las
elecciones ahora por supuesto
Cruzada que el partido de correa ha
llamado directamente a la muerte Cruzada
claro por supuesto y el partido de
correa obviamente o el correísmo o
Revolución ciudadana obviamente lo que
quiere es elecciones anticipadas Por qué
Porque lo que se tiene que hacer es
salir de este gobierno neoliberal que ha
llevado al absoluto fracaso al actual
situación en el Ecuador Porque si
miramos Los indicadores el propio si
miramos el plan de gobierno creando
oportunidades se hablaba de intentar e
ir de el puesto 93 en cuanto a
corrupción al puesto 50 en el año 2025
después del gobierno de Guillermo lasso
ya estamos en el puesto 101 cuando
miramos la inversión extranjera se
intentaba incrementar
quinientos millones de dólares al año la
inversión extranjera el año pasado fue
solamente de 51 cuando miramos también
los índices de desigualdad el índice
gini llegó a 0,47 puntos el año pasado
es decir la peor cifra en los últimos 15
años y así sucesivamente por supuesto Ah
bueno Y después por supuesto las cifras
de inseguridad 5,7 muertos por cada
100.000 habitantes en el año 2017 último
año de Correa y hoy
25,5 muertes O sea induplicado la cifra
por cada 100.000 habitantes por supuesto
que hay que llamar a elecciones es que
el actual burgomaestre de este país no
lleva el país sino la deriva ahora el
juicio político no es el mecanismo para
las elecciones anticipadas la muerte
Cruzada así entonces por supuesto que el
correísmo y a la luz de las elecciones
pasadas locales en las que se obtuvieron
plazas tan importantes como guayas
Guayaquil quito pichincha decir las
principales obtuvo el correísmo una
victoria histórica
la población claramente se ha decantado
a favor del correísmo eso indica
claramente que va a haber una victoria
del correísmo en las próximas
presidenciales y que la gente lo está
pidiendo porque así ha ocurrido en el
referéndum en el consejo de
participación ciudadana en las distintas
selecciones de prefectos y de alcaldes
etcétera entonces Andrés usted está de
acuerdo con esta visión de que hasta el
momento el gobierno de lazo ha llevado
prácticamente por las riendas de la
perdición a Ecuador como lo planteando y
que responder ante esto y si esto está o
no relacionado con el juicio político
pero primero tenemos que tomar en cuenta
que aquí hemos hablado de falsedades
Como dice casado porque en efecto como
usted bien lo señaló el movimiento
Revolución ciudadana y el bloque de
uniones en la asamblea nacional en el
marco del juicio político se ha mandado
dos comunicados diciendo en el
presidente vea independientemente del
juicio político la muerte Cruzada Y
además lo que ha dicho es también el
expresidente de la República Rafael
Correa ha dicho no tenga miedo active la
muerte Cruzada prácticamente acorralando
al presidente de la república Y
obviamente que aquí no es cuestión de
defender la gestión del presidente lasso
que en efecto tiene varios errores tiene
muchos errores tampoco podemos
desconocer aquello Pero también es no es
loable que una asamblea nacional que es
la peor de la historia incluso que la
anterior que era más corrupta trate de
destituir al presidente se dice Ah no la
asamblea nacional está al lado del
pueblo una asamblea nacional que tiene
el cuatro por ciento de aceptación va a
destituir un presidente que tiene el 17%
de aceptación o sea aquí estamos 17%
por supuesto pero aquí estamos más bien
haciendo una competencia de quién es el
menos peor una asamblea nacional que
también ha estado en lo dada por actos
de corrupción de diezmos que se dedica a
resolver cuestiones que no solucionan
los problemas del país hace unos meses
declararon el día del mazapán el día del
bizcocho el día del perro eso es lo que
hace la asamblea nacional esa asamblea
nacional con esa calidad va a destituir
un presidente de la república y en ese
sentido yo creo que más allá del debate
político que podamos tener la asamblea
nacional también queda debiendo al país
porque si bien es cierto está haciendo
su trabajo que es del de control
político no ha resuelto los problemas de
inseguridad no ha aprobado leyes de
extinción de dominio no da trámite a las
reformas parciales que tiene que ver con
la complementariedad de fuerzas armadas
con la Policía Nacional entre otro
tantos normativas que requiere el país y
que está pendiente de eso cuatro meses
enfrascados en procesos de control
político y hasta la fecha ni una ley que
en realidad pueda resolver los problemas
de los Ecuatorianos y le quiero hacer
una contra pregunta porque usted dice
que la oposición quiere acorralar al
presidente Guillermo lasso y casi que
forzarlo a una muerte Cruzada sin
embargo el mismo mandatario ha dicho que
él estaría dispuesto a hacer un llamado
a una muerte Cruzada ante este juicio
político Cómo defender Entonces eso
el presidente de la república ha dicho
lo siguiente que la asamblea nacional no
le ha permitido gobernar
al menos tres leyes han sido negadas por
parte de la asamblea nacional
leyes que tienen que ver con la
transformación digital leyes en materia
económica la ley de comunicación
prácticamente salió en otro contexto y
es importante indicar que el presidente
de la república ha manifestado que el
día del juicio político va a desnudar a
los asambleístas que tienen relación con
el narcotráfico con bandas criminales y
que evidentemente por debajo de la mesa
están cometiendo actos de corrupción y
extorsión Así que también los señores de
la asamblea no es que son unos angelitos
y ellos están a la expectativa de que se
vaya el presidente lazo que asuma el
señor borrero cooptar y cogobernar eso
es lo que se pretende Y evidentemente de
esa forma llenar el camino de Cara a
unas elecciones anticipadas o para las
elecciones del 2025 aquí quiero hacer
una Claridad Y es que para que en
Ecuador el presidente pueda llamar a la
muerte Cruzada que ya como lo están
explicando nuestros panelistas es
disolver la asamblea y convocar gobernar
por decreto y convocar a elecciones
anticipadas para esto se necesita uno de
tres requisitos uno que el gobierno
considere que el legislativo no le está
dejando manejar y está obstruyendo su
plan de gobierno la segunda es que haya
una grave crisis o un y una conmoción
interior y la tercera y la última es que
el legislativo aplique funciones que no
tiene en este sentido el oficialismo
está un poco diciendo que el legislativo
que la asamblea está obstruyendo sus
planes y por el otro lado los opositores
y el correísmo constantemente están
apelando a una grave crisis y conmoción
interior estas palabras todo el tiempo
están en ese discurso Le quiero
preguntar a Fernando
en caso tal de que el presidente
Guillermo lasso sea destituido este será
el primer juicio político que hay en
Ecuador desde la constitución del 2008
Qué implicaciones podría traer esto
lo primero haciendo una alusión directa
lo que tú acabas de decir en el caso en
el que triunfe este juicio político pues
obviamente se habrá dinamizado lo que
tiene que ver con las institucionalidad
democrática tengamos en cuenta que en
cualquier democracia el balancees es
fundamental no los pesos y contrapesos
entre los distintos poderes ejecutivos y
legislativo no podemos tener un poder
por encima del resto al igual que por
ejemplo una democracia parlamentaria una
moción de censura siempre celebrada en
el sentido de dinamiza el juego
democrático ahora cuidado con hacer
afirmaciones temerarias benavides no
decir que esta es la asamblea peor de la
historia o sea
De dónde viene el argumento Dónde está
el dato que esta asamblea es tiene mayor
corrupción que el anterior por temas de
diezmos De dónde viene el dato yo trato
de ser muy serio cuando hago mis
afirmaciones yo trato de respaldar todo
lo que digo con datos concretos entonces
o hablamos argumentos o hablamos de
pareceres sesgados pero yo creo que es
más serio hablar de argumentos y
efectivamente ambas instituciones en
este momento tanto el presidente de la
república Guillermo lasso tiene uno de
los peores sino el peor indicador de
popularidad y también la asamblea
nacional ecuatoriana tiene unos
terribles índices de popularidad y de
confianza en la población por eso mismo
es tan importante salir de la situación
de crisis política en la que nos
encontramos y sobre todo en una
situación en la que sea nada más y nada
menos que en la región más violenta del
mundo que es América Latina se han
quintoplicado los niveles de inseguridad
el Ecuador en el año 2017 último año de
Rafael Correa tenía uno de los
indicadores de mayor seguridad en el
Continente por no hablar de todos los
estándares sociales incluido desigualdad
pobreza etcétera y hoy en día están en
los peores indicadores del continente
hoy en día la desigualdad en el Ecuador
es comparable a los peores indicadores
de toda la región a la par de Somos el
tercer país más es igual junto con
Colombia y con Haití Y ese es el gran
problema María Clara y por eso Además
del peculado en el que por supuesto
incidido por el caso flopec el
presidente por el cual se le lleva el
juicio político aquí hay un problema de
institucionalidad y de crisis y por
supuesto el Ecuador necesita
alternativas y salir de un gobierno que
es un gobierno que Hasta ahora ha sido
una losa para el país un país a la
deriva Sí y según usted cómo salir
Entonces de esa crisis Cuáles pueden ser
las soluciones juicio político muerte
Cruzada
desde luego que ahora mismo el juicio
político va a darle un recambio al país
no es decir si salimos del presidente
Guillermo lasso Pues otro será quien
esté al frente del país y desde luego yo
sí creo que después del fracaso de las
elecciones del 5 de febrero después de
lo que está siendo el Cómo se han
aglutinado las distintas fuerzas
políticas no solamente el correísmo
aunque sea el mayoritario en la asamblea
pero otras muchas fuerzas políticas de
muy diversas índole en torno al juicio
político aquí lo que se está demandando
es claramente unas nuevas elecciones
aquí lo que se está demandando es un
recambio de quienes están dirigiendo y
administrando el país porque actualmente
tanto en el ámbito económico como en el
ámbito social como en el ámbito de
seguridad el actual gobierno es un
auténtico desastre está claro No Y ahí
hay muchos mecanismos democráticos para
hacer un recambio en la dirigencia de
quién está al frente del poder ejecutivo
Andrés y se necesita ese recambio según
usted o usted considera que esto es una
presión de la oposición en un intento
por retomar el poder
Bueno yo antes de responder a su
pregunta respecto si es que existen
datos sí Obviamente que existen datos va
a estar revisar la los informes del
observatorio legislativo de la asamblea
nacional y Cuántas leyes han aprobado
Qué se ha hecho en la asamblea nacional
eso en lo numérico ya en lo fáctico
tenemos una asamblea nacional donde un
asambleísta violó a una mujer embarazada
en horas laborales antes de presentar
una denuncia en la fiscalía general del
estado en contra del presidente de la
república Y tenemos a una de las
acusadoras que tiene serios problemas
personales tiene algún interés personal
con la empresa flopec en donde
supuestamente dieron haciendo desde una
oficina de la empresa para favorecer en
este caso eh la vigencia del contrato
con amazonas pero más allá de eso creo
que es importante tomar correctivos
tomar correctivos que permitan
solucionar la grave crisis institucional
que vive en nuestro país y en ese
sentido yo sí puedo decir que el Ecuador
a partir del año con la consulta popular
de Moreno prácticamente se partió el
tablero institucional dejando
autoridades transitorias dejando
autoridades que más bien velaron por los
intereses de unos pocos en lugar de los
Ecuatorianos ejemplo de aquellos que
tenemos casi seis años sin contralor
general del estado por otro lado yo creo
que sí hay que hacer cambios en materia
económica Totalmente de acuerdo me
parece interesante lo que ha pasado en
esta semana en el cual el gobierno
nacional ha firmado un una deuda el pago
de deuda a través de la protección de
zonas
naturales del país y evidentemente el
principal problema que ahora tenemos los
Ecuatorianos incluso por encima del tema
económico es la inseguridad porque los
Ecuatorianos no sabemos que si vamos si
al salir de nuestras casas vamos a poder
regresar Ese es el principal problema
que ahora tenemos los Ecuatorianos y hay
que hacer un cambio de 180 grados que
nos permita superar aquello y
posteriormente retomar el tema económico
porque sin seguridad sin la tranquilidad
evidentemente no puedes abrir los
comercios no puedes generar inversión y
no puedes usar la economía Andrea Pero
entonces usted coincide en un punto que
plantea Fernando y es uno reconocer que
hay una crisis institucional y dos decir
que la seguridad es el principal
problema de los Ecuatorianos en este
momento Cómo salir entonces ante estas
crisis
Bueno yo creo que en este caso
lo que se debería hacer es replantear la
forma de gobierno que ha hecho el
presidente de la república creo que
debería ser el cambio de algunos
ministros que no estuvieron preparados
para asumir esta responsabilidad por
otro lado yo creo que se deben hacer
acuerdos políticos sobre la mesa en el
cual nos permita generar condiciones de
gobernabilidad y en el caso de la
asamblea nacional yo esperaría que este
catorce de mayo donde se van a elegir
nuevas autoridades se plantee una agenda
legislativa Que responda a las
necesidades y requerimientos que tenemos
los Ecuatorianos Pero principalmente
al plan Nacional de desarrollo y a los
ods y también a los objetivos de
desarrollo
a los diferentes objetivos que tenemos
como país que evidentemente pueden ser
transformados en política pública si
hacemos eso yo creo que al menos
podríamos salvar los muebles pero no
podemos desconocer la grave crisis en
todos los ámbitos que está viviendo
actualmente el Ecuador yo creo que claro
con una destitución de lazos se va a
solucionar los problemas de inseguridad
con una muerte Cruzada se van a
solucionar los problemas económicos Si
esa es la salida que lo hagan de
inmediato pero si eso es solo Un
capricho político Ahí estamos hablando
de otra cosa capricho político o la
salida para esta crisis institucional
Fernando usted qué piensa para usted
Este es un intento de golpe de estado
parlamentario como lo cataloga lazo o
por el contrario es la respuesta a una
crisis institucional pero con la que
Correa Quisiera regresar al poder Usted
qué opina
bueno igual Mara Clara voy a hacer un
par de incisos antes de contestarte a la
pregunta no a ver reloj Cuidado con las
temerarias afirmaciones No yo lucino con
que un abogado constitucionalista hable
de dos casos que son recientes y que
están en proceso de investigación como
que si fueran ya hechos probados y
definitorios no como acaba de afirmar en
torno a dos ejemplos que ha mencionado
de asambleístas eso desmantela uno de
los principios fundamentales del derecho
que es la presunción de inocencia y está
cambiándolo por una presunción de
culpabilidad eso no se debería de hacer
no Porque todo el mundo es inocente
hasta que no se pruebe lo contrario eso
por un lado por otro también en cuanto a
las estrategias que ha presentado
Benavides para mejorar los índices de
seguridad se acaban de hacer el habla de
cambiar ministros y los ministros se
cambiaron Prácticamente la semana pasada
no eso también lo que demuestra es que
no hay forma de salvar al presidente
lasso en cuanto a sus políticas de
seguridad porque fíjate María momento en
el plan creando oportunidades
2021-2025 que el propio presidente
Guillermo lasso presenta normalmente las
víctimas por inseguridad se miden por
cada 100.000 habitantes y es lo que
planteó en ese programa creación de
oportunidades fue bajar desde el 2021 al
2025 de 105 a 100 las muertes por cada
millón de habitantes Fíjate que que
cutre no
voy a pedir que redondee la idea que
lastimosamente se nos está acabando el
tiempo Vale pues María Claro que te digo
es que en vez de haber bajado de 105 a
100 ha subido a 255 y que efectivamente
no se puede llamar golpe porque es un
mecanismo institucional establecido en
la constitución del año 2008 Por lo cual
lo que se hace es dinamizar una
democracia que tiene mecanismos para
salir de un poder ejecutivo cuando este
no cumple con sus compromisos con su
plan de gobierno como está ocurriendo
actualmente y que por lo tanto hay
mecanismos para salir de él por qué
otros poderes como la asamblea nacional
poder legislativo pueden hacer juicios
políticos y posteriormente Ojalá haya un
anticipo de elecciones porque
actualmente no hay salida esta crisis
Andrés y su conclusión para terminar
para ustedes un golpe de estado
parlamentario como lo defiende Guillermo
lasso o es un juicio político con el que
Correa Quisiera regresar al poder
Bueno yo creo que ni lo uno ni lo otro y
yo ahí sí voy a discrepar con a quienes
Con quienes piensan que el juicio
político es un golpe de estado es un
mecanismo de control político que
evidentemente tiene algún tipo de
interés para poder cooptar caro donde
ledes esa es otra cosa y hacer ese
bypass constitucional para poder
gobernar
No sé desde dónde pero algunos también
están pensando es que con este mecanismo
de alguna forma se podría tratar de
traer al ex Vice al ex presidente de
correa pero para que ocurra aquello
tienen que darse varios factores el
primer factor es que tiene que ser
declarado inocente en la justicia porque
tiene una sentencia condenatoria
ejecutoriada el momento que pide Ecuador
va en privado de su libertad a menos que
a través ya de estando en el poder se
presenta un recurso de revisión y con
eso se tume todo el proceso penal pero
eso es otra cuestión yo en realidad en
el corto plazo creo que al menos ese
objetivo no va a ser posible porque
existen sentencias condenatorias de por
medio que que que van a ser difícil
darle la vuelta en ese sentido más allá
de las deficiencias que pueden tener las
claro y que también tenemos que ver cómo
se resuelve este juicio político y que
esperemos hacia finales de mayo tengamos
la respuesta de la asamblea ecuatoriana
André Benavides y Fernando casado
Gracias por acompañarnos lastimosamente
se nos acaba el tiempo y a ustedes
nuestra audiencia En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos por su sintonía
la producción de este programa estuvo a
cargo de Andrés doncell y la producción
de invitados con Tania Herrera ustedes
sigan dejando todos los comentarios y
sigan conectados con France 24
[Música]